madame monsieur bonsoir la france a
perdu la bataille mais la france n'a pas
perdu la guerre
il y à 45 ans jour pour jour c'est en
ces termes que le général de gaulle
lançait à la bbc depuis londres l'appel
du 18 juin
il tournait ainsi la première page de
l'histoire de la résistance que l'on
commémore dans les principales villes de
la région
ce soir aujourd'hui se souvient ton de
ce mot de ce mou de ce moment historique
l'enquète de laurence bobillier
qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour toi le 18
juin 1940
la libération c'est l'appel de de gaulle
samedi à bamako la libération en fait le
pas grand chose j'ai entendu ça à la
radio après l'appel de de gaulle depuis
londres
la pétition en sa femme est revenue le
général de gaulle qui a visé ce quelque
chose d'important français savaient même
pas pris la peine
je crois qu'on a été à paris j'étais à
paris mais je m'appelle puis bien fait
je serai du tout
l'appel du 18 juin
j'ai pas dis tu savais comme je serai ni
le début de la guerre je ne fais ton
histoire terminale ont pas l'appel du 18
juin du général de gaulle à partir de de
l'ombre voilà comment le seul c'est
l'appel de de gaulle à la con ce titre
c'est ça ouais saviez comment il dit
plus grands singes français la france
il est là
et par le fonds français